tras tres años sin sentarse formalmente
la otan y rusia han retomado las
conversaciones con las tensiones en la
frontera de ucrania como plato fuerte el
secretario general de la otan jens
stoltenberg ha admitido que la reunión
de hoy no ha sido fácil pero que se ha
conseguido un compromiso para volverse a
reunir y definir un calendario para
futuros encuentros y seguir abordando
todas las cuestiones que aún se tienen
que hablar el encuentro de hoy ha durado
una hora más de lo previsto aunque han
podido hablar de cuestiones espinosas
como por ejemplo la presencia de tropas
aliadas en el este de europa así como la
presencia de tropas rusas en la frontera
de ucrania y también las presiones de
moscú para que países como ucrania o
georgia nunca lleguen a formar parte de
la alianza atlántica algo que los
aliados rechazan porque recuerdan y
rusia no puede ser quien decida el
futuro de la alianza ni de los países y
por lo tanto tampoco tiene ni siquiera
derecho a veto para decir y este
encuentro se ha producido justo después
de que ayer moscú y washington se
reunieran en ginebra y paralelamente se
produce cuando los ministros de defensa
y los cancilleres de la unión europea se
reúnen a partir de hoy en francia para
poder abordar el papel de la unión
europea en estas conversaciones tanto
washington como la otan han asegurado a
la unión europea de que se la tendrá en
cuenta que no se tomará ninguna decisión
sin su consentimiento lo que teme
bruselas es que rusia quiera ningunear a
la unión europea rebajándole su papel en
el mundo y así también poderla dividir